[Musica]
avete mai pensato di tracciare una linea
su una mappa una linea che indicasse un
percorso da un punto a a un punto b e
avete mai pensato di percorrere quel
percorso a piedi
noi sì e lo abbiamo fatto noi siamo il
laboratorio del cammino un team di
studenti e ricercatori di 7 diverse
università italiane che hanno scelto
così di innovare i metodi di ricerca
studio e didattica dell'urbanistica
all'interno dell'università
io sono sereno marchionni e cordino
questo progetto ma lasciate che vi
spiega in due parole qual è il compito
dell'urbanistica l'urbanistica è una
disciplina che ha il dovere di prevedere
e progettare le trasformazioni dei
territori e delle città è una disciplina
molto particolare perché infatti i suoi
confini sono mobili ed è per questo che
i nostri tutor non sono tutti urbanisti
e pianificatori sono infatti esperti di
altri saperi come l'ecologia la
fotografia e la linguistica ma forse vi
starete chiedendo perché usare il
cammino per studiare urbanistica infatti
potrebbe suonarvi assolutamente stramba
e bizzarra l'idea di prendersi circa
dieci giorni di tempo per correre 200 km
o forse di più a piedi in gruppo e
prepararsi così a sostenere un esame
universitario infatti camminare non è
come uscire a fare due passi si spende
molta parte della nostra giornata a
mettere un piede dietro l'altro solo per
raggiungere la meta però è un metodo
straordinario per che rivoluziona la
percezione che abbiamo del mondo
la cambia infatti uscire dai dalle
strade dei tracciati principali ci
consente di avere una rinnovata
attenzione sulle cose che ci circondano
e l'incedere lento del nostro passo ci
permette di pensare meglio e soprattutto
andare oltre i limiti della propria
fatica ci consente anche di esplorare
noi stessi in un certo senso soprattutto
facciamo scoperte continuamente ad
esempio quest'estate attraversando la
sicilia tutta a piedi dentro i boschi di
casaboli e di angimbè abbiamo scoperto
l'odore del bosco che ricrescere perché
questi boschi erano stati incendiati
circa un anno prima è potuto ammirare
come le fronde delle querce da sughero
resistano all'incendio è solo un anno
dopo rifiorì sero dai tronchi
carbonizzati e incontrare delle persone
meravigliose che le notti d'estate
siciliane quelle percorse dallo scirocco
quelle più a rischio incendio perché
calda e ventose queste persone
organizzano da soli volontariamente dei
turni di vedetta del bosco e così
abbiamo capito quello che non si trova
sui libri cioè che la popolazione spesso
volontariamente si fa carico di problemi
di gestione del rischio incendio
problemi che noi ci riguardano
direttamente come urbanisti quindi e
fuori dall'aula
fuori dall'aula e attraverso il
territorio ascoltando chi lo abita che
abbiamo scoperto che spesso sono i
luoghi a suggerirci possibili
interpretazioni e collegamenti e oggetti
di studio
provate a immaginare per un attimo di
essere in cammino da cinque giorni ad
agosto caldissimo e di stare per
arrivare ad arquata del tronto un borgo
marchigiano colpito dal terremoto del
2016 e attraverso lunghissimi salite vi
state preparando insieme a una classe di
circa 30 persone a osservare questo
borgo medievale completamente raso al
suolo dal terremoto ea vedere lì
immediatamente di fronte le casine
emergenziali in costruzione mentre
camminavamo
i ragazzi parlare con loro parlare tra
di loro delle problematiche di
ricostruzione post sisma e si
interrogavano su una questione la più
importante di tutte quanto fosse stata
efficace la strategia di politici
amministratori di costruire proprio lì
le casine nuove di fronte a quello che
rimaneva del paese una volta arrivati
delle persone fuori dalle loro roulotte
ci accolgono e ci offrono delle prugne e
li abbiamo interrogati su questa
questione e ci hanno risposto che la
dove noi vedevamo le macerie loro
vedevano casa e che non avrebbero
preferito vivere in nessun altro luogo
camminare quindi è un modo straordinario
per cambiare prospettiva e soprattutto
farlo in modo interdisciplinare con dei
tutor di altri saperi ci consente di
prendere in prestito strumenti di
indagine e osservazione e arricchire
così il nostro punto di vista
camminando
attraversiamo molto lentamente luoghi
non siamo affatto veloci però accade una
cosa velocemente si cambia velocemente
si cambiano le nostre idee sul mondo i
nostri pregiudizi le nostre convinzioni
e cambia anche l'idea che abbiamo di noi
stessi di chi incontriamo e di chi
viaggia con noi noi attraversiamo dei
territori e lo facciamo perché un giorno
saremo chiamati a governare questi
territori a prevedere i cambiamenti che
interesseranno a tutelarli sono i
territori però di cui tutti noi un
giorno dovremmo prenderci cura la
storica dell'arte rebecca solnit dice
una cosa che a me sta davvero molto a
cuore dice che camminare è un modo per
costruire il mondo ogni anno abbiamo un
obiettivo attraversare un transetto
della penisola italiana
magari da mare a mare e lo facciamo per
studiare per conoscere questi territori
il primo a mano
e per cercare di descrivere aspetti non
ancora scovati non ancora scoperti o
descritti di essi ma soprattutto per
trovare un nuovo modo per vivere in essi
grazie
[Applauso]